Do you have a Brother color
changer stashed away somewhere?
Now is a great time to pull
it out and give it a try.
I have to admit, I've never used a color
changer before,
and I was really stumped
by the instruction book
for installing this thing.
But with a little perseverance,
I conquered it.
Let me share.
Before you get as frustrated as I did,
do a little research and confirm that your
color changer can be
used with your machine.
I discovered after a whole lot of fussing
and fuming that this model is KCC.
Model color changer is not compatible
with my Brother bulky 260.
Now, if you don't have a manual for your
color changer, you should be able to find
it in our free manuals and documents page.
Now, I had a printed manual
and it's on the cover.
It said it's model KCC.
And doing a little research, this appears
to be the same as the KHC 820 manual.
This is a single bed
color changer.
Can't be used with the ribber.
I was able to connect my new toy
to my brother 970 by using the KHC arm
connector that comes
with the color changer.
This allows me to keep
my ribber in place.
The color changer device itself is held
in place on an arm that is inserted
into that connector
and puts everything right in place
for the carriage to pick up the colors.
Now, as I was connecting everything,
at first I couldn't get the arm
into the connector until I realized that I
needed to tilt it up a bit
and slip the pieces together.
Lesson learned, don't force anything.
It will slip into place very easily.
Once I figured all this out,
things went more smoothly.
Included with my color changer
is a yarn tension setting stand.
Now, this one had me stumped.
I couldn't figure out what it was for,
and it's a clamp that adds a place
to insert the second yarn mast.
Apparently, on the older machines,
this piece was needed.
Thankfully, on my 970,
there's already a spot right in the bed
itself for that extra yarn mast.
Well, thankfully,
because this little stand didn't fit
anywhere on my machine
and I don't need it.
Following the manual once I get everything
into place, I was surprised and pleased
to learn that it was fairly simple
to thread and use the color changer.
Here's an overview
for working with four colors.
First, change to the color
changer sinker plate.
Now, along with the color changer device
with all the buttons,
this is what's really going to be
doing all the work for you.
Now notice you have to tilt that sinker
plate to pass it over the sinker posts
and slip it into place under
the knobs of your carriage.
So be careful in inserting it.
It's a little different than the others.
Put two tension masts in place
and thread up the masts with each color.
To make things easier.
If you're using a stitch pattern
that has colors marked 1-2-3-4.
Be sure to arrange the colors
in the color changer accordingly.
Thread up each color in the color changer.
Now, I tried to make this
harder than it really is.
All you have to do is push in, say,
button 1, and thread the first yarn
around the yarn guide
and in the groove of the roller.
Now, you shouldn't have to struggle.
The yarn pops right into place.
Continue
for each color,
I recommend that you peek from the back
to make sure there's no hang ups and each
of the yarns are correctly in place.
When all four colors are threaded,
loop them around and secure them
underneath the yarn holder.
So now you have your hands free, the yarns
are threaded up, and they're secure.
My first experiment,
I started with no needles in work.
Just to keep things
really clean and simple.
Push in button 1 and pass the carriage
all the way to the left
past the turn mark.
In other words,
you want to pass the carriage far enough
for the guide on the carriage to grab that
color that's pushed out by button one.
Push your carriage back to the right
slowly and confirm that you
picked up color 1.
Don't go too far right,
we don't want to be pulling too
much tension off this yarn.
Push the carriage back to the left.
Push in button 2.
Now remember to push that carriage as far
left as you need to to catch color 2.
Push the carriage right and back again.
Each time, confirm that you
picked up the right color.
Now, when playing this way,
you want to be sure to milk the cow.
I like to keep the tension on the colors
so the yarn doesn't loop up.
As we're playing here,
the whole experiment is to learn and get
a feel for how far past that turning mark
you need to go to catch
the yarn in the carriage.
For my first try at knitting,
I unthreaded everything.
And just for practice,
I changed back to my regular sinker plate
and I cast on some stitches.
I started all over, changed
to the color changer sinker plate.
I used the slip setting to position
the carriage on the left
side of the knitting.
We want the carriage
on the same side as the yarn.
I then rethreaded the color
changer for practice.
Make sure everything's moving
and in the right place.
Be sure to disengage all four
of the buttons and secure those yarn
tails under the yarn clip on the arm.
Just like before.
I pushed in one button,
passed the carriage all the way to the far
left, far enough to engage the yarn.
Push the carriage back and knit a few rows.
To change colors
pass the carriage all the way to the left.
Push in the button
to select the next color.
Confirm that the yarn is
in position in the sinker plate.
The right color has been chosen
and knit back.
Knit a few rows of stripe
in the second color.
There you go.
Keep trying different colors
to get into a slow, steady rhythm.
I did find that if I tried to knit too
quickly,
or if I took the carriage too far past
the right side of the knitting,
I not only distorted the stitches
on the right side, but I often got a loop
where the yarn got caught up
in the mechanism underneath the carriage.
So this takes practice to get the right
rhythm and to make sure that everything's
working as you're knitting.
Like everything else in machine knitting,
I discovered there's an art
to using this color changer.
You need to slow down, confirm the colors,
and just take it easy.
It's still a whole lot faster and easier
than changing colors manually.
Now that you've been successful
in knitting stripes, I hope you've
been successful in knitting stripes.
I encourage you to go back to your manual,
the color changer manual,
and reread everything.
I found that even though I struggled,
all the information I needed was there.
I just found it difficult at first.
Once I saw how things were supposed
to work, it got a whole lot easier.
Now, your challenge is to master stripes,
no loops, no stitches pulled out of whack,
and then play with multicolored
stitch patterns.
So much fun.
And this allows you to do so many things.
Now, one thing to note with stitch
patterns is that punch card and electronic
stitch patterns have to be reversed
for working with the color changer.
You can see an example in my manual.
The little teddy bear
is punched in reverse.
Now, if you have an electronic machine,
you can just use the little reverse key
or you'll have to punch your cards
correctly for the best results in using a
single bed color changer
to knit in stitch pattern.
I hope seeing a color changer in action
helps, and I hope you have
success with your color changer.